in Toronto Canada ringmaster Scott
McClellan takes the stage for Scott
who's stage name is Nikolai Diablo
shocking a willing audience is a
full-time profession while others might
spend their time toiling in offices
Scott eats razor blades drinks boiling
water and hammers nails up his nose we
brought to the public something that was
sorely needed in our plastic humdrum
yuppie eyes dworld in carnival Diablo
Vanessa meal keeps alive a long and
perilous tradition so many people before
me have died on stage start swallowing
and that's what the audience is buying
the very real danger that these
performers will seriously injure
themselves or even die right before
their very eyes there's at more of its
sense of curiosity that draws the
audiences and constantly because we are
taking our life into our own hands
and I think that's one of the reasons
people come because if they can't take
the risk themselves at least they can
witness it in the world of extreme acts
few can rival tim cridland his stage
name is Zamora the torture King his game
self-mutilation skewered run through the
arms exit wounds entrance his cheeks are
permanently scarred from shoving
hundreds of skewers through them Tim's
fascination with pushing his body to the
limit began at age 10 with a book about
strange performers through history fact
is I'm just kind of emulating the pass
in fact that's pretty much what I
specialize in kind of replicating these
things that are completely lost in a way
I swallow one of Tim's most popular acts
is eating a light bulb long as get
bitten off a little more than I can chew
I'm gonna hammer over here yes there's
no turning back
the highlight of Tim's act is when he
slides a razor-sharp skewer all the way
through his arm
I've kind of linked up my mind and body
in a way that if I choose not to feel
pain I can I can overcome that you can
actually lower my blood pressures that's
one of the reasons that doesn't plead as
much as you think it would know better
than that there's my matter while some
people can't bear to lunch many others
just can't look away and that mix of
poor and fascination is keeping the
sideshow alive in the 21st century